hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
plato's dialogue the ion
is important for aesthetics because it
has to do with poetry
one of the main characters ion is a
rhapsode that is an interpreter
of poetry who specializes in homer
and so we're looking at the nature of
poetry the nature of interpretation
what it is that goes on you know in in
the response of the
audience and and i've got another you
know core concept video specifically
about that about the
metaphor of the rings and enthusiasm but
dialogue is also just as much about
knowledge and who can claim to have
knowledge
in it socrates ends up confounding
ion really in some ways unfairly because
he's going to say some things
which seem on their face quite plausible
but if we accept them entirely
and i'm going to say we don't actually
have good reason to accept them entirely
and i think socrates himself and plato
know this
then they're going to lead us to certain
operas or impasses
when it comes to thinking about the sort
of questions that are coming up
now one of the key issues that
gets discussed in here is this notion of
speaking well or speaking poorly and
and what role is that playing in the
dialogue
what does it have to do with knowledge
notice i've got this diagram up here and
over and over again in in the dialogue
you're going to see
socrates saying things using examples
that
really sketch out something like this
he's going to do this with all sorts of
arts and skills and sciences
and the question that he's really
concerned with
is is poetry
or its interpretation
a body of of knowledge
why is this important well the ancient
greeks actually did look to homer and
arcologists and hesiod and the dramatic
playwrights
for providing them with certain kinds of
knowledge
now you know does that mean that they
would take everything
from homer when it came to chariot
racing and homer was the last word on it
and they would never you know think of
anything else on their own
no but they thought that you know homer
is writing about chariot racing
and homer can actually tell us something
competent
from the standpoint of somebody who does
possess
skill or art or knowledge they they
think of the poets
like homer for example as being kind of
polymaths they
they know a lot of different fields and
that makes them an expert so somebody
who has a skill or an art or a science a
techne or an episteme
in in greek thought he has knowledge
they have disciplinary knowledge that
makes them an expert
and that allows them to speak on the
subject matter that that
art or science bears on so for example
if we take
medicine you know one of the examples
that socrates likes to use quite often
there is a discipline of medicine and it
bears on
the body and its health and the humors
and you know the elements and things
like that
somebody who's become an expert
possesses the knowledge that's needed in
order to
produce health each subject matter has
its own
end its own good state that it can be in
and so if you ask
a doctor about something they're able to
speak well about it they're able to
speak we might say instead of speaking
well
they're able to speak competently
they're able to give you good
advice about things and since you're not
a doctor
you may not actually be able to
understand or
even fathom the knowledge that they have
you just say oh okay you know i'm
supposed to take these pills i'll take
these pills
you want me to lose weight i don't see
why i should but you know you're the
doctor so i guess i'll do that you want
me to quit smoking all right i'll quit
smoking
um it's the same thing for
for other things the carpenter has
knowledge
that the non-carpenter doesn't have and
if they
take the time they can't explain a lot
of it but there will be some parts of it
where unless you're actually trained in
the discipline it's probably not worth
their time to do that
so they're able to speak well about it
and
you do well to follow somebody who
speaks well provided that they're not
trying to mislead you
or anything like that here's where it
gets more complicated
socrates also says
the person who it's the same person who
can tell
who else is speaking well and can tell
who
else speaks poorly here's where it gets
tricky in the dialogue
so presumably another doctor
can tell if that doctor over there is is
bs'ing you because he's trying to you
know get an extra fee
or he's your enemy and he wants you to
drink poison or something like that
he can tell whether that other doctor is
actually telling you the the straight
line or or something crooked
whether he's speaking well or speaking
poorly the doctor can also tell
what you know if joe blow off the street
comes in and says hey i think
this is my diagnosis of your ill health
and here's what you ought to do
um try this this this herb
or you know do jumping jacks for 10
hours a day
that doctor because he possesses medical
knowledge
he can say that person speaking poorly
they don't know what they're talking
about
so this makes good sense for anything
that involves
disciplinary knowledge i mean carpenters
may disagree about exactly how a certain
problem wants to be solved
but they agree on certain basic
principles that are dictated
in large part by the material that
they're working with
when we get to other you know areas it's
a little less
clear you know statesmanship law
aesthetics even cooking to a certain
degree
you know when we're looking at the
aesthetic side and not just the
scientific side of it
um but in general you know a chef can
tell if another chef is full of bs or
not
um or you know just somebody essentially
pretending to be a chef
it gets a little tricky when we get to
other disciplines
like if we're thinking about poets
can a poet tell
whether another poet is speaking well or
speaking poorly
well this gets to the question what what
are poets actually talking about and
we're going to look at that in another
um another section now
one of the other things that socrates
says that's particularly
important to pay close attention to is
he says there's this assumption
subject matters are distinct and what
that means
is that the skills or arts or sciences
the bodies of knowledge that experts
have are likewise distinct
they don't overlap they they don't stray
into each other's territory
so when the poet is for example
discussing chariot racing who would be
the person that you would go to to find
out whether the poet is actually
speaking well about that or speaking
poorly
if we want to put this in our own um
our own realm of experience think for
example of all the tropes that they use
in hollywood that if you know anything
about the subject matter you say
that's that's completely wrong um you
know when they do space movies for
example
explosions in space you you can't
actually hear them and
all the science people point out yeah
you know not only in space can no one
hear you scream
all the aliens in space nobody can hear
you on fire nobody can hear you shooting
things nobody can hear you doing
anything because there's no
air to convey sound myself
i was a combat engineer in the army so i
got to see a lot of explosions
including explosions with that that you
know most favorite of filmmakers
uh explosives to reference c4
right and what you find out is that
there's not a lot of flames to
explosions
also with grenades um there's there's a
lot of
stuff you know going around there's some
smoke
but there's not a lot of fire you don't
have a huge fireball
you know i always laugh when i watch
these movies where
something is happening and it's it's
this tiny little bit of c4
and somehow it blows up an entire
building that's because i actually know
about it now
did the scriptwriters know about it did
the director know about it in this
parlance we would say that they were
actually speaking poorly even though
they were telling an entertaining story
they were speaking poorly um we might
say the same thing about what about
psychological thrillers you know
is it is it the the audience who should
decide whether the
you know the script writers are speaking
well when it comes to primal fear
or would it be practicing psychologists
this is why they often bring in experts
to you know help out
with with movies and
we might say the same thing about all
sorts of other types of artistic
production
novels um songs um
you know what whatever you like so
the question then is
going back to homer if homer is actually
speaking well about
chariot racing it's not because of him
being a poet it's because he actually
knew
something about chariot racing and then
he's only speaking quoi
chariot racer not quoi poet
but homer talks about all these
different things
and who would decide you know if he's
actually speaking well about numbers a
mathematician
who decides if he's speaking well about
cuisine
a cook who decides if he's speaking well
about
medical knowledge a medical person so
socrates is going to use this as a wedge
to try to say that the poets really
don't know much about anything and like
i said we'll get to that
in another one where we ought to be
really
worried is here
so this this person who can tell when
somebody else is speaking well
or speaking poorly are they somebody
who's
in the discipline or is it possible for
us to
generalize as socrates himself is doing
about this notion of speaking well or
speaking poorly how do we actually know
that it's only somebody who possesses
that knowledge
who can tell whether somebody else is
speaking well or speaking poorly
unless we ourselves possess that
knowledge
in which case we have to know about
all the different subject matters and
that's clearly not the case so there's
kind of a strange
instability of ideas if you actually
look closely at this dialogue
but here's here's the basic idea behind
this speaking well
the person who speaks well does so
because they they possess
knowledge they are able to speak
competently about some
subject subject matter